كان ذلك قبل عام امام السجن ريمون في
صحراء النقب كانت لحظات صعبه لانه ودعت
اصدقاء العمر
ثم لحظه ما فتحولي باب السجن لقيت مخابرات
الشباب بينتظروني وتم اعاده اعتقادي مره
اخرى
بس المشهد اللي كان صعب انه لما اطلعوني
في السياره شفت والدتي
وابوي واخوتي بينتظرونا فكانت صعبه يعني
نشافوني مره واحده مره واحده تم اعتقادي
كمان مره بعد سبع ساعات في معتقل
المسكوبيه في القدس افرج عن شادي
تعرف على الوجوه بفعل الصور والرسائل التي
كان يتبادلها مع الاحبه والاصدقاء
نادر تصله هديه من اسير رفيقي دربه
نادر صدقه محكوم ست مؤبدات من
الطائفه السامريه
لكن الاص
امهات رفاقه الاسرى
كن كامل مضى حرم خلال سنوات الاسر كباقي
الاسرى من معاني الحياه الطبيعيه البسيطه
افتتحا هو وشقيقه مشتلا يمضي فيه ساعات
لكن المنغصات كبيره
وقانونيا انا مسحوب بهويتي ممنوع اتواجد
في القدس فعمليا انا بدون بلا بلا هويه
بلا تعريف بلا متوقع سحب الهويه مش شيء
بسيط لانه انت ابسط الشغلات الحياتيه
اليوميه ما بتقدر تسويها يعني
انا بقدرش افتح حساب بنك لما اتوظف لاني
بطاقه قويه انا بقدرش اتزوج
تحققت بعض مطالب الاسرى من خلال الاضراب
عن الطعام على مدار عقود يعني ابسط
الشغلات مثلا الحق بالزياره الفرشه الفرشه
حققت من خلال رابعه الطعام عدد 1981
التلفزيون حقق من خلال الاضراب عن الطعام
استمر 17 يوم الثوره هي ساحه السجن الباحه
تحت السجن كان مسموح للاسرى فقط ساعه
واحده وكان القصر يفرض عليهم سابقا اني مش
متقاطئين الراس وان يخاطب السجان بكلمه يا
سيدي
ولاحقا من خلال رابعه الطعام كسرنا هذه
المساله وصار في عنا ساعات اطول بالفورا
وبطلنا انه خاطب السجان يا سيدي اما ابسط
الحقوق وفق القوانين الدوليه فيحرم منها
الاسرى الكتب الاكاديميه تنفع ما زالت ومع
ذلك نضل كغيره من الاسرى الاستكمال
الدراسه فحصل وهو داخل الاسر على رسالتي
ماجستير ويحضر لرساله الدكتوراه ويستعد
لنشر كتاب عن الصهيونيه عمل لسنوات داخل
الاسر ان جزء كبير من الادويه اللي احنا
بناخذها احنا بندرك اسرى انه هذه ادويه
تجريبيه فاصبحنا الان فئران تجارب يعني
كمان لموانا نتحدث عن الكثير من شهداء
اصدقائنا اللي دفنناهم يعني دفننا شهدائنا
ودفنا اسرارهم معهم ان يقف الفلسطيني امام
نفسه امام المراه ماذا فعلت لاخراج الاسرى
داخل السجون في اشي دائما بنحكيه بينه
وبين الاسرى المحررين
بنقول احنا طلعنا من السجن بس السجن ما
بطلع منها
الجزيره القدس المحتله